okay the history of john mcafee
is throughout he he
throughout the 80s and 90s right he was
he was living large at
some point i think it was in the 90s he
sold his part of
uh mcafee antivirus to microsoft he got
100 million
right when he should have got billions
and years later it was worth a ton more
yeah right right
and he was a nut he was a nut his dad
committed suicide his dad was an
alcoholic
a lot of people say he's a [ __ ]
egomaniac on top of it yeah
he's definitely his narcissistic so if
you're him
and it's and this is anything
narcissists don't kill themselves
i'm never i'm not killing myself there's
no way
i'm taking out everybody else i can
right right right that's a good point
that's a good point i mean yeah that is
hardly ever happening sorry but go go
ahead so i'm saying the guy's
he's obviously a [ __ ] egomaniac and
he had a problem with drugs big a big
problem with drugs and alcohol and he
was a little [ __ ] loopy
more than a little loopy right just
judging by his twitter so
if i'm john mcafee and i'm i am
depressed and i am considering suicide
why not just
[ __ ] with everybody three and a half
years three to five that's it three and
a half
three to five okay i thought it would be
way worse i thought they'd try to make
an example out of you and try to like
pin you to 20 years ago i mean if you go
to
trial you know can you get 30 years yeah
you can
right nobody nobody takes that no
nobody's going look if you're if you're
just
blatantly guilty right especially when
your others are saying i'm not
paying [ __ ] taxes you have no trial
okay but he did some other scammy [ __ ]
he pulled he pulled some bitcoin scams
he tried he did some bitcoin pump and
dumps where he tried to like ask like
like pump the price a bit but they
haven't i don't think that's not i think
he was indicted for tax evasion though
it was only that only tax
like they may have superseded alex jones
said he was a spy
alex jones said that he was a spy for a
bunch of other countries and
doing all kinds of crazy [ __ ] anyways my
what i was getting to about about his
personality and his pookiness and his
drug abuse [ __ ] like that
right if i'm him and i do want to kill
myself
why not [ __ ] go crazy and try to [ __ ]
with the
try to [ __ ] with the internet and just
make some sort of crazy legacy for
myself and say
hmm maybe i do want if i do want to kill
myself maybe i'll [ __ ] tattoo on
myself
whacked and make the whole world think
when i go out that i got whacked by the
feds
i mean yes why not just try to troll
people and make some sort of legacy out
of it yeah i mean why try to [ __ ] with
people
because do the fads like how much do
they give a [ __ ] about john mcafee
i don't know how much do they really
give a [ __ ] a guy who committed tax
evasion and did some bitcoin pump and
dumps
maybe he's got some info i mean i mean
he
yeah that was the other thing he said he
had all this uh was it
three terabytes or something whatever
megabytes or whatever though he had some
info
he had info on corruption and so what
first of all that that that part didn't
even like phase me it's like oh come on
stop
yeah there's this thing there's this
thing called a like he's like he's
raymond reddington from the blacklist
like he's got
like i'm gonna expose the cabal
what's the term there's a term for
people who uh who
uh it's like a uh i forget what the
[ __ ] word is
but it's basically like a term for like
when a suicide bomber like you like a
suicide bomber comes in and someone
shoots you
you let go of the trigger and you
everyone gets oh it's a dead man switch
a dead man switch
yes a dead man switch so that's like
what he what he kind of had was a dead
man switch
so if he got like if he got a bullet if
he got killed the switch would go off
and all of the info all the [ __ ] that he
would have in everyone would get
released right
where is it right exactly that's what
they say about epstein too like why
wouldn't he have a dead man switch
because he wasn't he didn't have
anything and he
killed himself epstein i think
i think he's killing himself no epstein
you don't think epstein had anything
come on um where is it i think he killed
himself
epstein i just can't imagine that you
could get into a federal print like
a lot of guys are like this look so i
i've like
zach was telling we were arguing um and
it was
the argument was he was saying well why
not just wait till he gets back here
right and kill him back here because
it's easier to get to him
in a spanish prison and then there's an
investigation in a spanish prison
and how much do they give a crap about
some american that died in a spanish
prison
you get them back here how are you going
to get into the marshall's holdover
it's difficult this is these things are
inside of pens and they're
it's not it's it's not it's difficult
what does it say
john mcafee tweeted before his death
that he stored computer files in a
florida condo building that later what
scroll down a little bit
that later collapsed what i've heard
this one
is that real this is
this i think this is false news because
it's on politifact that means it's a
fact
the name of this website has the word
fact in it
it's clearly true it's undisputable
doesn't mean that
conspiracy theories escalated quickly
around the death of technology
entrepreneur john mcafee in a barcelona
prison where he was waiting extradition
to the u.s on tax evasion charges
spain's el paris el paella el pious
newspaper reported that mcafee
who developed the first commercial
antivirus software blah blah blah blah
blah blah
keep going keep going oh cue on
he posted it uh scroll up a little bit
and see the queue and on
june 25th instagram post appeared to
link mcafee's death to june
23 with another major news event the
collapse of a condominium building near
miami the next day
what the next day
huh yeah did you see the thing at the
top
look great stop stop stop see where it
says q and on
right but rumors linked to the uh
baseless q anon conspiracy theory
uh whose followers believe uh what
democrat democrat celebrities were
involved in an un
underground child trafficking ring
suggest oh yeah yeah yeah
uh cover it by queuing on often soon i
don't know you know what the collapse of
the building reminds me so it's a q and
on theory that he hid the
hid the files in that building yeah
listen listen okay so when i was locked
up in
in uh was that the medium
yeah i was in the medium when i was in
the medium uh at coleman
so i worked with this guy every day
for a year talk to them at least
you know five minutes here you know like
any worker i worked in the library at
one point
so i taught real estate classes i worked
in the library and then at another point
i taught ged but for like a year so i've
worked in the library so i see this guy
all the time he's
like the head librarian nice guy we're
always talking we talk a little about
this a little bit about that politics
what's going on because at that time i
would watch the news and everything
totally normal guy everything was super
normal talked about movies everything
guy's normal
one day i happen to say so you're still
you're still working on your case he's
like he looked at me and goes yeah
yeah but uh after oklahoma city i just
don't know um
i don't know what i'm gonna be able to
do i mean i can't get the
these the the evidence is destroyed and
i went oklahoma city and he looked at me
and he goes
timothy mcveigh and oklahoma city you
know unit the oklahoma city
yes of course and i went what does that
have to do with your case like this guy
knew this guy had been locked up like 20
years
way before oklahoma city and he and he
said
the fbi was storing the evidence in
my trial at the field office in oklahoma
city and i said i
thought you're you were prosecuted out
of orlando
and he's like i was but that's where
they were storing the files
by the way that's absolutely not true
that's not where your store your files
are stored
yeah okay there is no storage in a field
office in oklahoma city
all right they're stored at the u.s
attorney's office or at the fbi
at the field office where you're being
prosecuted out of which he wasn't
you ever been to oklahoma city no why
were they stored there
exactly exactly so he goes they
they he was they bombed the
the uh fbi field office and took the
building down
to destroy my evidence his evidence his
evidence
so they killed like 30 some odd kids a
bunch of fbi agents a whole bunch of
other people working in the building
they framed timothy mcveigh all to
destroy your evidence to keep you in
prison because you got 30 years you've
already done 20 of it you got five left
this guy always seemed normal
for a year well how do you know maybe
maybe his files were stored there how do
you know
how you know they weren't insane they
are you just said he was normal up to
the point he said this one thing right
he had this
look you could talk to frank amadeo and
have a great conversation with it
with him until and just happen you could
do it for a year and then one day you
happen upon
something and he starts telling you
about how he's going to take over the
world some of these guys have these
little tiny little it's this little dark
dark
room somewhere in their head and one day
you're opening up doors and you
open that one door and you find out the
guys in this that's
[ __ ] nuts yeah that one little crate
that's these the
q and on guys but isn't there a
conspiracy there is an fbi i don't i
don't know anything about it but there
is a conspiracy about
about the oklahoma city bombing right
except for the fact that when they
talked to timothy mcveigh he laid out
exactly what he did
he didn't say i was hired i was framed
he was saying he's like yeah this is
what i did
i was uh i was uh yeah because they
[ __ ] brainwashed them with mk
ultra okay let's move on they
brainwashed that's insane
what are you doing they [ __ ] brain
washes out using lsd
oh my god listen half the guy is on
youtube
i'm spitting facts
[Laughter]